sin importar el ganador todos los
candidatos se comprometieron a mantener
la paz después de conocer el resultado
los aspirantes a la presidencia de
Nigeria firmaron un compromiso de paz en
donde prometieron resolver en los
tribunales cualquier inconveniente que
se presente después de las elecciones
del próximo sábado
Permítame recordarles a todos los
nigerianos que este es el único país que
tenemos y que debemos hacer todo lo
posible para mantenerlo seguro Unido y
en paz no debe haber disturbios ni actos
de violencia después de la asignación de
los resultados electorales todos los
agravios personales o institucionales
deben ser canalizados a los tribunales
correspondientes
con el presidente del año pasado cuando
el fraude estropeó las elecciones
anteriores la comisión electoral
nacional independiente asegura ser más
firme y profesional para impedir que el
escenario se repita entre tanto las
autoridades buscan dar confianza a los
más de 93,4 millones de votantes
registrados en el país más poblado de
África en donde la inseguridad el
aumento de la violencia islámica se
presentan como una amenaza para que la
jornada se desarrolle en las condiciones
óptimas
una problemática que quien quiera que
reemplace al presidente muham bojary
deberá enfrentar sumado a la corrupción
sistemática que desmotiva la inversión
extranjera la elevada inflación y la
escasez de efectivo que se dio tras la
introducción fallida de nuevos proyectos
de ley a finales del año pasado
con todo el panorama los nigerianos
votarán el sábado en una de las
contiendas electorales más reñidas y
determinantes de su historia desde que
terminó el gobierno militar hace casi un
cuarto de siglo y en la primera en la
que un candidato que no pertenece a los
dos partidos principales tiene
oportunidad de ganar